where do you place yourself and how do
you do the layout of the land of Bernie
Sanders AOC Joe Biden and uh David
backman my instinct is and the I'm going
to answer it the thing that makes this
tough is
Bernie says I'm he's a Democratic
Socialist he ran as a Social Democrat he
didn't run on anything that was really
socialism right so I'm going by their
public facing platforms I've been
listening to him for many many years and
uh all the way back to the Thom Hartmann
Show and I think using the terms as
you've been using them yeah he has I
don't think ever been a Democratic
Socialist I haven't heard him speak
about socialism
I think I've heard him speak about
social programs and the value of social
programs yeah throughout the history of
the United States and there and how
they've been beneficial my understanding
is very similar to yours although there
may be stuff from the 70s where he
really was talking about in the 70s
yeah yeah you and I even who weren't
around we were doing stuff I feel like
we did yeah my sense would be you know
Biden is like Center left and then I'm
to the left of that
but maybe just inside of where AOC and
Bernie are very very similar to Bernie I
mean I I identify with a lot of Bernie's
ideas
maybe their implementation I'm more
flexible on I'll give you one example
Medicare for all
one way of trying to get health care to
everybody which Bernie's very big on is
you take the current Medicare program
you just eliminate the age limit make it
available to everybody pay for it
through taxation interesting however I'm
open to other models if they get
everybody health care that is
good quality and affordable Singapore
has an interesting model Germany has an
interesting model I am I am more
agnostic about how we do it than just
saying let's expand Medicare whether
that puts me to the right of of Bernie I
don't I don't know but I'm not like
exactly right there on it has to be
Medicare for all yeah that's more of uh
that's more just flexibility versus
dogmatism so I don't know if that puts
you to the left or to the right I don't
either what do you think about the
who could term manipulation or the
corruption in the DNC that perhaps tip
the scales against Bernie in the
election do you think there was that
2016 or 2020
[Laughter]
uh both I would say uh in different the
Dynamics there were different with
Hillary Clinton and um like the pressure
from Hillary Clinton as a candidate and
so on yeah what I mean was there why
didn't Bernie win I guess is one one way
to ask okay
I think there's a couple things here
first the DNC I'm not a Democrat just
your audience may not know I'm just a
independent yeah I mostly vote for
candidates that end up being Democrats
in local elections often there's no
party designation so okay I'm obviously
on the left I'm not denying that but the
Democratic party is as an institution
has never really been interesting to me
you're still a rebel that resists
belonging to any institution exactly
right exactly right and whether it
matters I I don't know
um the DNC and the RNC really are
organizations that to some degree exist
to justify their own existence because
if they were no longer necessary
they would go away and so they have to
assert their value and their importance
they do this in a number of different
ways organizing the way that the nominee
is chosen the convention uh working with
States on everything from redistricting
to whatever else the case may be setting
the order of primaries and having some
involved and how that's all going to
happen and also coordinating behind the
scenes uh I guess they would describe it
as making sure our candidates don't get
in each other's ways we might see it and
say they're picking the the winner
there's nothing illegal about them being
involved in picking the winner but we
might say it's not in people's interests
I think the 2020 primary was really
interesting Bernie supporter myself
I started telling my audience after
a couple primaries and even before based
on polling and different things
I see a real uphill battle here for
Bernie
and it's really important people in my
audience are not the average you know
union worker in Michigan who is mostly
working and raising a family and then
goes to vote on primary day and goes to
vote on Election Day
if you spend a lot of time on Reddit and
Twitter you're going to have an inflated
sense of Bernie's popularity within the
Democratic Party
that was my sense
and to some degree
we saw that in certain States I don't
have the exact primary order and results
in front of me or in my head but the big
turning point was South Carolina
South Carolina was when Joe Biden won
and won handily
understood to be because of the larger
African-American population in South
Carolina
and right around that exact same time I
actually don't remember now whether it
was the day after or the day before some
of the smaller Democratic hand that it's
smaller in terms of support got out and
said I'm endorsing Joe Biden and to some
degree of course it was all organized
and timed to help Joe Biden there's no
doubt about that this is what the DNC
does it's hard for me to be mad at the
DNC because this is sort of like if if
we believed they were there to be
unbiased Arbiters and to stay as much on
the side as possible it would make sense
to be furious that they've gone against
their stated you know kind of mandate
but we know that the DNC
negotiates and is working behind the
scenes and has a favorite that favorite
was Hillary in 2016 2020. so I share the
frustration about the power that the DNC
has but for people who were saying they
did something illegal or whatever else
the case may be that that doesn't seem
to be the case but this is part of why I
mean I would love there not to be this
duopoly of Republicans and Democrats and
there's probably four major changes that
have to happen in order to make that a
reality but I share the frustration of
folks while recognizing
that Reddit was not accurately
representing Bernie's level of
popularity still I wish that the bias
wasn't towards the uh what could be
negatively termed a deep State towards
the bureaucracy towards the momentum of
the past which I think Joe Biden kind of
represents uh versus new ideas which is
funny to say that Bernie Sanders somehow
represents new ideas because he's also
an older gentleman well it's a frame
it's a lot of Framing and the other
aspect to that is on paper
Joe Biden's platform was arguably the
most Progressive of any Democratic
candidate who won the nomination now of
course there were people who challenged
the nominations who were to Joe Biden's
left a lot of this is perspective and it
it you know that's how you end up saying
the guy who's a couple years older than
Biden is actually the guy with the fresh
perspective which is interesting because
I don't disagree with you
yeah and you also have to say the
perspective doesn't always align with
the policies you're right and you know
the actual policies that Joe Biden are
different than the maybe the perception
of Joe Biden or what he ran on I mean
just two examples I would give are
during his campaign he played up a
little bit his interest in doing student
loan forgiveness and something on
cannabis I never bought it I told my
audience I think he's saying this stuff
because this is the way the tide is kind
of the wind is blowing and he's being
advised to say this stuff I don't think
he's going to do very much on either of
these things he did actually do some
student loan stuff but that would be two
examples I think